"Mortal Kombat Legends: Battle of the Realms"
follows the franchise's animated debut,
"Mortal Kombat Legends: Scorpion's
Revenge," which introduced viewers
to an animated take on the Mortal Kombat universe.
Here's the ending of "Mortal Kombat
Legends: Battle of the Realms" explained.
To begin discussing "Battle of the Realms,"
it's important to understand where "Scorpion's
Revenge" left off in the world of Mortal Kombat
Legends. As usual in most retellings of the famous
original Mortal Kombat Tournament, Lord Raiden,
protector of Earthrealm and god of Thunder,
brings together Earth's champions to compete in
the Mortal Kombat tournament — designed by the
elder gods to allow the realms a chance to fight
for power over one another. In Earthrealm's case,
it's a chance to protect Earth from an
incursion by the forces of Outworld.
In the final moments of the tournament,
Scorpion intervenes and beheads Goro
just before the monster can deliver a
finishing blow to Liu Kang. Scorpion
also manages to trick Shang Tsung and obtains a
special key to free the mad elder god Shinnok.
Thanks to Scorpion's interference, Earthrealm
wins the tournament and Liu Kang is crowned the
winner as a result. Scorpion kills Sub-Zero,
believing him to be the culprit behind the
orchestrated deaths of his family and clan, but
it's revealed that the Netherrealm sorcerer Quan
Chi actually committed this heinous crime.
Scorpion finally obtains his revenge as he
brutalizes the sorcerer before finishing
him off. In the aftermath of that fight,
Scorpion resigns himself to another
death as the island crumbles around him.
After a short prologue, "Battle of the Realms"
quite literally begins with a battle between
realms. Sometime after the tournament, Outworld
plans and enacts an invasion of Earthrealm.
Kitana, who is still under the thumb of Shao
Kahn, is leading the forces of Outworld in an
all-out offensive. Special forces figures like
Sonya Blade, Jax Briggs, and Curtis Stryker take
up defensive positions against the incursion with
the help of Kung Lao and Lord Raiden. Apparently,
Earthrealm's victory in the Mortal Kombat
tournament is being ignored by Shao Kahn.
During the battle, Shao Kahn enters
the battlefield, but not to fight.
He offers Raiden a chance to resolve the
conflict through one final tournament,
and Raiden agrees, seizing the opportunity to
save future generations from the responsibility
of defending Earthrealm by ending it all here
and now. Shao Kahn and Lord Raiden petition
the elder gods to make the tournament happen.
Shockingly, Raiden also sacrifices his godhood
in order to participate in the
tournament alongside his heroes.
While the rest of the characters are waging
war against one another, Scorpion finds himself
back in Netherrealm following his fated battle
with the villainous Quan Chi. However, instead
of Quan Chi this time, it's Shinnok, a corrupt
elder god, who greets him. Waiting patiently,
Shinnok seeks to use the key Scorpion obtained
from Shang Tsung to unlock an ancient power. The
problem is that the key has now fused itself with
Scorpion's soul, so Shinnok threatens Scorpion
with eternal pain and torment should he not use
the power of the key on the Temple of Elements.
But Scorpion doesn't take kindly to threats, and
he quickly ditches the elder god and his minions.
Elsewhere, Kuai Liang and Smoke, members of the
Lin Kuei, train before being commanded by their
grandmaster to bring Scorpion in alive. Liang
is reluctant to accept the mantle of Sub-Zero,
but is emboldened by the thought of killing
Scorpion, who murdered his brother Bi-Han.
Ultimately, the grandmaster betrays his own clan
by damning them to a life of programmed servitude
as cyborgs, and Cyrax and Sektor appear
as newly constructed cybernetic warriors.
The grandmaster wishes the same for Sub-Zero
and Smoke, and in their struggle to escape Cyrax
and Sektor, Smoke is taken by the cyborgs
and eventually converted into one himself.
As promised by Outworld's ruler Shao Kahn, as
well as Lord Raiden, a tournament commences that
tests the mettle of each realm's champions. True
to the video game franchise, the fights pack a
bone-crunching punch followed by countless buckets
of blood and gore. Some combatants lose, but are
lucky enough to be spared a grisly death, like
Johnny Cage and Jax. Others aren't so fortunate.
Quickly, Curtis Stryker and Kung Lao are
eviscerated by prominent Outworld combatants
Shang Tsung and Shao Kahn. The combat is bloody,
vicious, and thrilling for fans of the franchise.
At a pivotal moment, Kitana is ordered
by Shao Kahn to fight Raiden, and while
both are competent fighters, Kitana gains the
upper hand. Ready to unleash a killing blow,
Kitana strikes — seemingly hitting her true
target, Shao Kahn, with her blade. Seeking freedom
from his tyranny for herself and the realms,
she defects and joins those opposing Outworld.
Shao Kahn, however, isn't finished; he vows to
make Kitana watch as he destroys the realms.
The tournament continues with Liu Kang and Shang
Tsung. The sorcerer disables one of Liu Kang's
arms with a curse, but the Shaolin warrior
manages to defeat Shang Tsung regardless.
Despite being manipulated by his grandmaster
and losing Smoke to the cyborg program,
Kuai Liang still harbors deep-seated anger toward
Scorpion for the murder of his
brother Bi-Han. Interestingly,
Scorpion regrets killing Bi-Han, and has
learned that vengeance is an empty pursuit.
Despite their differences, the duo determines
that they must join forces against the Lin Kuei
cyborgs to stop them from using the key to
unleashing disaster upon all the realms.
Their attempt to stop the impending doom is
foiled, however, when the two are overwhelmed
by the cyborgs. Scorpion is taken to the
Temple of Elements and forced to place
his hands upon the door to open the ancient
vault. Inside the temple lies a Kamidogu,
one piece of many that when collected summon the
power of the One Being. The Lin Kuei grandmaster
delivers this piece of the Kamidogu to Shinnok,
who is revealed to be the clan's client.
In the lore of the "Mortal Kombat" video
games, particularly "Mortal Kombat: Deception,"
the One Being is considered the progenitor
of the realms in the Mortal Kombat storyline.
Before life as we know it among the realms truly
began, the One Being and the elder gods existed
as the deities within the universe. The elder
gods sought to remove the One Being's limitless
power by dividing the deity among the realms as
artifacts known as Kamidogu. Anyone capable of
uniting the Kamidogu pieces with a sacred amulet
would obtain the godlike power of the One Being.
As the story goes in "Battle of the Realms," it
is known that the mad god Shinnok has vigorously
sought the One Being's power so he can merge
the realms and wipe them out of existence.
The Lin Kuei grandmaster and his cyborg puppets
merely act as mindless mercenaries doing Shinnok's
bidding. Upon realizing Shinnok's true identity
after giving him the final Kamidogu piece,
it's apparent that the grandmaster knows he's
made a terrible mistake. But he doesn't get
to sit with that reality long, as Shinnok
calls upon the forces of the Netherrealm
to destroy the grandmaster and his cyborgs.
By the time Kuai Liang and Scorpion arrive,
it's too late: Shinnok has started
merging with the power of the One Being.
After a long and arduous tournament with
plenty of death to go around, the tournament
delivers one final blow: Raiden accepts the
challenge to face Shao Kahn in Mortal Kombat.
The barbaric dictator beats the former thunder
god and kills him, much to Liu Kang's horror.
But before Liu Kang's friend and mentor
meets his end, he is sure to tell Liu that
even though his parents died when he was very
young, they died protecting and loving him.
This is the fire Liu Kang needs heading into his
fight with the Outworld leader. After finding
some inner strength and harnessing his chi, Liu
Kang is able to dispel Shang Tsung's curse on his
arm and defeat Shao Kahn. He then frees Kitana
from her imprisonment, and the group begins to
celebrate the victory. But, unfortunately,
they're unable to get too far along in the
celebration before the elder gods appear and
alert Liu Kang to the impending challenge ahead.
Shinnok takes on the power of the One
Being and grows to a massive size.
With the absorption of the deity's
power comes the merging of the realms.
All the realms begin blending together, which
means humans in Earthrealm are now at the mercy
of the ravenous denizens of Outworld. While
the realms are consumed in chaos, the elder
gods lend their power to Liu Kang so he can
attempt to defeat a seemingly invincible being.
With his newfound power, Liu Kang takes the form
of a massive dragon not unlike the one you see in
the famous Mortal Kombat logo. Through the history
of the video game series, Liu Kang has been known
to perform fatalities and animalities where he can
morph into a dragon and chomp on his opposition,
so we're in familiar territory with this
one. While Shinnok and Liu Kang engage in
a giant battle at the center of the merging
realms, the rest of Earth's champions scatter
to assist helpless civilians from the chaos of
the moment. Liu Kang almost meets his match,
but the deadly duo consisting of the newly
adorned Sub-Zero and Scorpion intervene before
the giant Shinnok-One-Being monstrosity
can deliver a killing blow to dragon Liu
Kang. The dragon then manages to retaliate and
finishes off the giant deity for good. Then,
using his divine power, Liu Kang separates
the realms and puts things back in order.
Nothing has been confirmed regarding a
"Mortal Kombat: Battle of the Realms" sequel,
but it's a strong possibility. After
all, why create a new MK series brand
called "Mortal Kombat Legends"
and stop at only two titles? Also,
a few threads are left open for potential
future storylines. Shao Kahn has been defeated,
but he wasn't killed. In fact, Jax poses
a question in the film's final moments.
On a happier note, the elder gods likely restored
Raiden to both life and his full thunder god
glory. As the camera pans out of the arena into
the end credits, we can see the familiar lightning
strike that often heralds Raiden's arrival. We
simply have to see Liu Kang and Lord Raiden's
reunion. Raiden's death was tragic for the young
warrior and it'd be nice to see the two tackle
a new world-threatening issue together. "Mortal
Kombat" lore is filled to the brim with heroes and
villains, so there's no shortage of possibilities
for the future of this animated series.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.